bonjour et bienvenue pour ce nouvel
épisode de probablement peu spécial
coronavirus puisque c'est vraiment la
côte chaude est descendu que
personnellement en tout cas moi je suis
assez préoccupant je suis très préoccupé
par ça j'ai [ __ ] part ça et du coup
c'est avec grand plaisir que j'accueille
aujourd'hui thibault fiolet qui fait sa
thèse en épidémiologie tient sa santé
publique et donc est ce que tu veux
quand c'est l'heure pour par nous
raconter un peu ton parcours pendant
scolaire mais du coup j'ai fait un
double diplôme d'ingénieur à
agroparistech où je m'étais spécialisé
en nutrition humaine et j'ai complété sa
avec un master 2 d'épidémiologie donc
c'est là où j'ai un peu plus approfondi
cette cette matière j'ai entre temps
avant de commencer le dr hage un peu
travaillé pendant deux ans au ministère
de la santé en belgique dans tout ce qui
est politique de santé publique et
sécurité alimentaire
j'ai également travaillé un tout petit
peu de trois mois allant ne cesse donc
celle agence nationale de son côté
sanitaire pour les aliments en
évaluation de risque alimentaire
j'ai commencé une thèse steiner ok avec
toi aussi une chaîne youtube s'appelle
qui volent violent et un blog et qui
s'appelle le quad en moyenne pour moi
comme pour fr.fr faire et donc même que
tu m'avais dit que le la situation avec
polémiques en tous cas du court en avion
c'est pas tout à fait exact de la
spécialité
oui en fait j'ai fait de l'épidémiologie
un peu des maladies infectieuses
durant ma formation mais actuellement je
suis quand même beaucoup plus
spécialisés dans l'épidémiologie des
maladies non transmissibles et ces deux
approches qui sont un peu différentes
après des similitudes bien entendu mais
c'est bien la logique
ok les gars se font maintenant que tu as
concept atteste du coup là ça fait cinq
mois que j'ai commencé ma thèse et c'est
sur les contaminants alimentaires comme
des résidus de pesticides ou des
additifs chimiques et les liens avec la
survenue du cancer du sein dans dans une
grande étude épidémiologique européenne
coordonnée par le ms hockey soit pas se
produire
oui mais du coup ça devient du coup là
le but tu vois ces deux d'étudier les
liens entre une exposition alimentaire
et la survenue d'une maladie
donc c'est un peu ce qu'on appelle
l'épidémiologie étiologique analytique
et par exemple pour les maladies
infectieuses on va plus étudier la
dynamique
donc là il ya tout ce qu'il ya l'aspect
du temps car en plus et c'est des
modèles un peu différent hockey qui sera
produit par exemple de l'écologie des
populations hockey et du coup la
recherche à ccc
j'imagine que c'est quand même beaucoup
de modélisation beaucoup de catholiques
oui c'est pas mal de stats des dons d on
a des données sur les consommations
alimentaires de 500 mille pattes sipan
on a également donné européenne qui
viennent de laives ça donc c'est
l'autorité européenne de sécurité
alimentaire donc sur les niveaux de
contamination dans les 28 pays union
européenne
donc dans plein de produits alimentaires
à peu près 3 millions de lignes et en
fait on va le combiné c'est ces données
de contamination avec les données de
consommation alimentaire pour estimer
dans quelle proportion les gens sont
exposés à des contaminants ensuite on va
relier ça avec la survenue du cancer
puisque en fait c'est une étude qui a
été lancé il ya un peu plus de vingt ans
par le le cirque
le centre international de recherche
contre le cancer et du coup on sait
maintenant qui au bout de 15 ans a
attrapé un cancer et on va faire des
une note positive étudier ça donc on va
préparer un petit peu plus d'actualité
donc quand on voit ce qu'on va suivi
cette histoire de cours d'un virus que
brasserie des états vous teddy ou la
séquence à devenir important là ouais
bah c'était seulement parce qu'en fait
moi j'avais commencé à lire des articles
dessus à s'étouffer en fait début
janvier il y avait déjà quelques
articles qui étaient sortis dans des
journaux plutôt anglais ou asiatique où
il parlait justement d'une pneumonie
inconnu mais après je me suis vraiment
intéressé au tour je pense du 19 20
janvier quand ça a pris un peu plus
d'ampleur dans l'est dans les médias et
tout ça et qu'on a découvert que c'était
vraiment un nouveau virus est pas jusqu
au départ on savait pas trop ce que
c'était et quand ça a été confirmé mais
c'était un nouvelle famille de
coronavirus je me suis plus intéressé ok
il a ce moment la ppa quel ou au départ
pas tellement parce que quand on regarde
et un peu les indicateurs
épidémiologique et puis au départ
également je pensais que ça allait enfin
je pense qu'un peu comme d'autres que ça
l'est peut être restée un peu en chine
n'est pas forcément se propager dans
tous les pays du monde et cet aspect là
au départ et qu'on a je pense peut-être
comme d'autres un peu sous-estimé cette
épidémie j'imagine comme dans les
premières pages parce que j'avais signer
sous estimé alors en janvier au dojo
ça serait pas difficile et avec le recul
je serai un peu plus facile plus tôt
mais ça reste difficile de parce que le
vent à ce moment là les données
n'indiquez pas que ça arrive souvent
comme sur deux de début de l'épidémie
qui finalement n'est pas grand chose
soit je vois oui bah si on prend
l'exemple du deux autres épidémies
grenet virus donc le le stress de 2002
2003 qui avait débuté
également en chine où le un autre corps
est vaine un autre coronavirus le maire
ce donc le syndrome respiratoire du
moyen-orient en 2012 en arabie saoudite
c'était quand même resté beaucoup plus
ces conscrits soit en asie où soi que
dans quand on arabie saoudite
il ya eu beaucoup moins de caf ça
s'était pas autant étendue et du coup
c'est quoi la différence entre pourquoi
est ce que cette fois ça s'est répandue
bah du coup ça c'est donc le stars' et
le maire s'est également de des ports
aux navires us on a également 4
coronavirus responsable des rhumes
commun donc une différence c'est que là
pour ce nouveau gros navires us il est
un peu plus transmissible que les le sas
houleux où le maire ce variantes pour le
syndrome respiratoire du moyen-orient on
savait que cette transmission
interhumaine elle était assez limité
elle se faisait également part contact
avec ses chameaux ou en consommant leur
lait leur viande
et dans ce cas là cette fois ci du
nouveau coronavirus de 2019 2020 on à la
transmission avec des personnes
infectées avec symptômes et sans
symptômes donc ça c'est un peu un peu
plus nouveau également sa transmission
avec les gouttes laisse les aérosols par
des surfaces contaminées et donc c'est
illégalement un peu plus transmissible
puisqu'on peut s'intéresser en
épidémiologie à des adaptateurs ont par
exemple y en a un c'est le taux de
reproduction de base ça évalue un peu la
transmissibilité du virus dont on peut
voir que la le donc ce taux de
reproduction de base appelée 0 c'est le
nombre moyen d'individus infectés par
une belle somme infectieuses si on la
place dans une population d'individus
qui sont susceptibles de pouvoir
attraper ce virus vraiment on peut
prendre que pour le nouveau coronavirus
dans les différentes estimations des
études ça tourne autour de 2 ou 3 c'est
à dire qu'en moyenne un individu
infection peut contaminer
deux ou trois personnes et si on prend
le maire ce donc le syndrome du
moyen-orient on était autour de 0 5 pour
si on prend la grippe saisonnière on
était également en également un peu plus
bas autour de 1,2 si tu prends l'exemple
de la ont démis du h5n1 en neuf ans
n'était à 1,46 pour le r0 donc là de
nouveaux corps d'un livret cela un peu
plus quand même transmissibles si on
casse tête comparaison et je pense qu
allemande différence par rapport à la
grippe ou d'autres maladies c'est quand
même c'est un tout nouveau virus donc on
n'a pas de traitement
on a pas de vaccin et également comme il
est tout nouveau
bah tout le monde est susceptible d'être
infecté il n'y a pas de d'immunité
active c'est à dire que l'art
théoriquement tournée susceptibles de
pouvoir être infectés alors que pour
d'autres virus déjà des gens qui ont
rencontré ce virus là et donc ils auront
peut-être une réponse immunitaire un peu
meilleur ouais ouais et est donc à ce qu
au moment où tu t'es dit ça ça va être
un problème
enfin quant aux questions et cette
absurde qu'est ce que donc il est resté
un peu vert vers janvier où s'étaient
pas énorme mais par la suite
bah je pense que c'est un peu plus quand
on a vu je pense que ce qui était
peut-être un peu plus inquiet dans ces
cantons regarder la situation en italie
donc un pays quand même un développé
comme nous et qu'ils ont également un
bon système de santé et on a vu que ça a
été vite submergée dans les unités de
soins intensifs et que du coup ça a
provoqué une augmentation du tout
létalité je crois qu'actuellement l'été
autour de 6 ou 7 % italie t elle encore
en asie il était quand même plus bas
autour de 2 3%
ça c'est également un autre indicateur
assez intéressant c'est le taux de
létalité est par exemple on peut voir
kahone il était un peu plus élevée que
dans le reste des autres régions de la
chine donc à oignies l'été autour de ses
impôts 6% alors que dans les autres
régions de la chine il était plus barre
inférieure et liées à la saturation du
système de santé donc l'accès aux soins
la qualité des soins qui joue également
sur ceux de l'état l'été et donc on a pu
voir également que le nombre de cas a
vraiment explosé en italie ou en iran et
donc ça me paraît quand même à quelque
chose de à prendre à la légère et de
même pour sembla de les chiffres en
chine et du coup la situation actuelle
que le bois claude basque est
actuellement quand même positif qu'on me
le dire c'est que par exemple sur la
chine qui a pris des mesures de
confinement d'isolation de de
quarantaine de one à ses toasts au tour
une sangle du 25 au 26 janvier
on a vu que ça a été assez efficace
puisque maintenant c'est un des seuls
pays avec la corée du sud où le nombre
de cas maintenant à l'air de se
stabiliser et que le nombre de nouveaux
cas a vraiment dû mener donc l'incidence
a a diminué et donc ils sont plutôt en
fin d'épidémie
également on peut voir qu'à singapour ou
à taïwan qui sont également des des
grandes villes et avec le des millions
d'habitants on n'a pas beaucoup de cas
parce qu'ils ont pris rapidement des
mesures assez importante d'intervention
en termes de traçage des cas dépistage
communication auprès de la population
donc c'est plutôt positif que 1 entre
guillemets ça peut s'arrêter même ça va
s'arrêter puisque c'est un peu le propre
de la dynamique des épidémies que en
photo au bout d'un moment avec les
interventions de santé publique du
gouvernement également que le fait que
les personnes infectées
après le liris et elles sont pas
respectables dans l'immédiat une sorte
de 10min épaisse
il attise deux groupes du coup le nombre
de personnes susceptibles d'attraper ce
virus va forcément diminuer pour cette
l'épidémie au bout quelques mois va
finir par s'éteindre y ait diminué et
donc et je pense qu'une des grandes
recommandations qui est prise à une
cuisse et ses deux voies du dhimmi part
augmenter la distanciation sociale et de
traction avec le but de d'aplatir la
courbe au chaud si un tricorne savez oui
c'est ça c'est ça à plat sur la croix
j'ai vu passer juste pour acheter
et ouais du coup ça c'est des mesures
efficaces puisque tu va diminuer le
nombre de contacts entre les gens le
nombre d'occasions le coût de
transmission du virus est ce qui est
intéressant dans ce type de mesure par
rapport à un isolement des cas infectés
c'est que cette mesure elle va toucher
les personnes indépendamment de leur
statut c'est à dire qu'on va donc
diminuer le nombre de contacts des gens
potentiellement infectées avec symptômes
et sans symptôme est également des gens
sains du coup ça va avoir un impact
vraiment efficace alors que également
quand on fait un isolement des cas en
quarantaine on cible spécifiquement les
gens qui ont des symptômes mais on peut
louper les gens sans symptômes c'est là
où par exemple la durée de quarantaine
et est assez importante a regardé par
rapport à la période d'incubation donc
la période d'incubation c'est le délai
entre l'infection et la survenue des
premiers symptômes
et on sait que pour le nouveau
coronavirus allait à peu prendre un à 14
jours en médiane autour de cinq six
jours il ya certes un rapport aux deux
cas qui ont estimé que mal pour elle
jusqu'à 20 jours ce qui est assez élevé
du coup c'est pour ça que là on a mis
une période de quarantaine d'à peu près
14 jours pour être sûr de pas
nous pdk est asymptomatique par exemple
un pas en mesure de prévention
ouais ouais est ce que parce qu est-ce
qu enfin sur une question un peu
différente mais est-ce que tu interdit
avec d'autres chercheurs
je pense qu'à une organisation des
chercheurs du domaine pour ça se passe
bien malheureusement pas forcément
tellement mais ce qui est assez
intéressant
j'avais jamais vu ça auparavant c'est
qu'il ya un énorme partage de données
d'accès libre en pour les publications
scientifiques comme ça que ça c'est
vraiment intéressant mais après par
exemple en termes de peut-être
coordination au niveau français je pas
tellement après je sais qu'au niveau de
la france il ya un groupe d'experts en
santé publique maladies infectieuses qui
a été mis en place par le gouvernement
mais ce qui est vraiment intéressant là
c'est qu'on voit que dans les grands
journaux biomédicaux d'habitude il faut
payer pour avoir accès aux publications
et là tout est en libre accès il ya
également les séquences génétiques qui
sont en libre accès sur ya aussi des
plateformes
on peut trouver très facilement les
programmes et script que les gens ont
utilisé pour faire leur modélisation
qu'un énorme partage de données sache
tout ça c'est vraiment bien et de
transparence c'était vraiment cool on
sent que ça se mobilise pas mal au
niveau des chercheurs de ce côté là nuit
et est ce que les autres choisissent que
la interagit avec certains autres est
l'épilogué qu'elle soit un peu leur
point de vue vous du coup moi j'en avais
un peu discuté avec des plus tôt des
amis qu'ils font
également un peu d'épidémiologie après
ce raid pour le moment c'est en fait
difficile de prédire comment la
situation va évoluer parce que j'ai
tellement de paramètres d'incertitude et
qui devait intervenir dans la dynamique
de l'est de l'épidémie donc pour le
moment c'est assez difficile de prédire
comment ça va se passer
c'est d'ailleurs une des raisons pour
lesquelles il n'ya pas tant de
publication qui travaillent sur des
modélisations de prédiction mais qu'on
s'intéresse plutôt aux données observées
actuellement de façon rétrospective pour
voir la dynamique de l'épidémie en prime
est passée fin sur les mois de janvier
février et mars et pouvoir
éventuellement comment ça va se passer
chez nous dans le futur on n'a surtout
pas mal de données au niveau de la chine
de passion chinois mais on sait que les
des différences dans les populations
occidentales et asiatiques
et donc on peut pas non plus forcément
tout copier coller en termes de
dynamique système de santé âge de la
population susceptible de viser par
exemple aspects des règles de la
distanciation sociale par exemple
oui la équipes sont sans doute ces
régulations sont peut-être un peu mieux
respectée dans certains pays asiatiques
que si on prend l'exemple de la france
par exemple pour le week-end dernier on
avait des gens qui faisaient la fete
dehors c'était un peu irresponsable mais
après je pensais peut-être des gens qui
ont un peu plus de mal à comprendre
l'utilité de ces mesures là je pense que
ça joue sajou également en la perception
du risque et lave la compréhension de
l'efficacité de ces mesures de
distanciation sociale ouais ouais je
vais passer un truc sur le monde de
l'interview je crois d'une psychologue
choses comme ça qui expliquait que
si les gens comprennent pas davantage
pourquoi est ce qu'il faut à distance et
social pourquoi pourquoi est-ce que le
virus est vraiment aussi menaçant alors
que si on y arrive finalement assez peu
de mort jusque là plus parler à d'autres
maladies si les gens comprennent pas
mesure pas l'ampleur du problème
ils sont beaucoup fin est assez
intuitive mais ils vont probablement
beaucoup moins à prendre les mesures de
appliquer les mesures de distanciation
sociale du coup j'ai l'impression que
nous autres en particulier vulgarisateur
scientifique avons vraiment un rôle
important à jouer à ce niveau là et si
d'expliquer tout ça tout le monde je
pense que nous en particulier bench ça
c'est sûr je pense que la communication
c'est vraiment est bien important dans
cette situation actuelle parce que
justement l'om est allé parler d'un faux
démis parce qu'on il ya une telle masse
d'informations de qualité plus ou moins
variable et je les ai vus également sur
les réseaux sociaux
au début de l'épidémie on avait bon
teint bleus de par exemple de gens qui
faisait des désordres toute prédiction
et on savait pas d'où venaient les
sources ni comment s'était fait défaut
avec des modèles exponentielle tout
simple mais souvent là la dynamique la
production d'une épidémie ça se résume
pas forcément je suis une exponentielle
et donc y avait pas mal d'informations
qui étaient plutôt fausses et sans
tournai est ce qui est d'ailleurs un peu
troublant c'est qu'ils sont ces
informations là seront beaucoup plus
relayé que les autres et veut même une
étude de danse cnd sa source à qui
montrait que les fausses d'information
était souvent beaucoup plus relayé d'un
nombre de cent fois mille fois plus que
les informations justes justement et là
c'est le propre de mon master bubble
bash genre pas sans savoir travailler ma
victoire au bol de me dire pour
compter que ce soit recommandée soit le
plus déjanté sur celle plus ou moins
fiables mais du coup j'ai très peu
d'idées de à quel point
en dehors de ce que je vois il ya ces
fausses informations
et j'ai vu aujourd'hui une vidéo de de
l'aspic tunnel qui est passée qui a été
fait sur le court on avait reçu lundi
dernier avant-hier et qui du coup montré
des images de ce qui passait à la télé
américaine
et c'était vraiment flippant perte de
mauvais diagnostics je crois qu'il faut
qu'un lien qui disait que s'il vous
arrive à retenir votre respiration
pendant 10 secondes c'est que vous avez
pas le choix aux navires us ce genre de
l'information est très très très
dangereuse à l'heure actuelle que parce
que planait gens ne pas prendre les
mesures de distanciation social alors
qui est rare que mal peut-être même ils
ont déjà les symptômes
puis quand tu vois que l' oms a dû faire
un un questions réponses pour par
exemple dire que l'oignon ne soigne pas
du corona mary axe essentiel ne protège
pas du coronavirus c'est qu'il ya quand
même un petit souci au niveau de
certaines informations en
[Musique]
ça paraît complètement invraisemblable
mais pour certaines personnes sans doute
un peu moins c'est ça qui est également
peu inquiétant je trouve ce qu est ce
qui a ses trucs un peu bêta puisqu'un
peu aussi galère c'est que j'ai
l'impression que je fais si on n'avait
pas envie moi j'ai pas beaucoup de
données sur les jeux pas beaucoup de
bonnes informations sur l'ampleur de la
mésinformation oui et qu'est ce qui doit
être fait et je sens qu'il ya beaucoup
de mes informations et quelques exemples
que décidée a déjà bien comprendre cette
mes informations et comment la combattre
au mieux c'est ça c'est aussi un sujet
facile mais j'avais trouvé par exemple
que l'initiative à singapour et et du
gouvernement était assez intéressante
puisqu'il avait créé
une sorte de gros points ça pouvait
envoyer directement aux gens tous les
jours des informations vous c'est pour
ça c'est intéressant puisque les gens
reçoivent directement des informations
fiables du ministère de la santé avec
les statistiques que les gens aiment
arrière et du coup sont pas allés à
chercher ailleurs
éventuellement sur des sites ou des gens
qui relaient des informations pas très
fiable et donc d'avoir directement de
l'information ça c'est aussi intéressant
après on a des sites d'information
intéressants comme celui de l'om est ce
au niveau européen de l'iss et 10,6 et
le centre européen de prévention et de
contrôle des maladies infectieuses je
crois au niveau des étals et les
ministères de la santé respectifs de 2
chacun des pays si par exemple on va sur
le style de santé publique france pour
la france c'est bien là y'a vraiment
énormément d'informations mais je pense
qu'il ya peu de gens qui vont consulter
ce site là et qui également connaissent
santé publique france c'est assez peu un
peu dommage ou où elle est consulté les
sites de l'institut pasteur
aie aie l'information donnée par des
professionnels de santé et pas des
inconnus puisque si on regarde même sur
twitter ce qui est assez marrant c'est
qu'on a vu enfin j'ai vu arriver des
comptes en janvier février qui qui
relaie plein d'informations des fois
c'est anxiogène et qu'ils sont
que son mini du coup avoir plein de
followers mais je me suis posé la
question même si peut-être que les gens
n'aiment pas hausser les informations
oxygène bizarre mais il se poser les
questions
je pense que c'est vrai j'aurais aime
pas mais ca y est ils ils signent très
addictif que et 6 et on se dit après
coup qu'on n'aime pas mais sur le coût
au clic clac dessus ou alors on va lire
oui je pense également que des pubs faut
aussi savoir se déconnecter un peu de
cette information puisque ça va
tellement d'utilité d'aller consulter
tous les jours le nombre de décès dans
le monde où le nombre de nouveaux cas on
sait que cela va évoluer rapidement
surtout en début d'épidémie et je pense
qu'une fois qu'on a vu les chiffres on
n'est pas obligé de le voir tous les
jours parce qu'après c'est normal
d'avoir un peu peur de se faire un peu
peur surtout sur mon n'est pas forcément
du domaine et comprend pas forcément un
peu de recul par rapport à tout ça pour
moi j'ai dit à certains amis new way mes
parents de dépôt couper les informations
et ça fait un petit point des fois aussi
je pense que l'information continue
waouh
moi j'étais pour le coup d'envoi d'alert
depuis depuis une semaine on va dire je
suis beaucoup beaucoup de choses mais
ouais c'est enfin il ya une boulimie
passait vraiment c'est comme la bouche
passé comme la malbouffe est une jeune
boulimie qui se crée c'est important de
couper de 50 ans dans les additifs
alimentaires au glyphosate
on a changé de sujet un peu
sensationnelle mais à l'arrière ça j'ai
aussi l'impression que c'est parce que
je pense que les gens sont passés les
images de gens dans les bars thi bich
moi je sais pas il ya un besoin de moi
j'ai l'impression qu'il ya un besoin de
quasiment faire peur à ces gens là parce
que c'est si on voir fait pas peur
non pas prendre de trucs sérieusement ce
que j'échoue je serais d'accord ou pas
d'accord avec ça je pense que je suis
assez d'accord
je pense que l'on en fait on a des flops
cette annulation même nous mêmes on peut
se dire que ce sera le voisin qui sera
touchée épanouie personnes dont notre
entourage
donc on réalise pas forcément le risque
d'être facilement justement contaminé
contaminer ses parents ou ses grands
parents qui sont des personnes encore
plus à risque pour ce virus là et que
cela peut avoir des conséquences
dramatiques en termes de santé je pense
qu'on s'en rend pas forcément compte
comme justement
enfin le virus n'est pas visible ni
baisse et il le sait je pense qu'il ya
un peu aussi de sa basse et ils menacent
pas facile à visualiser ça du coup il ya
un peu un juste milieu à trouver qui est
vraiment délicate on va trouver enfin en
sorte que les gens prennent les choses
sérieusement et qu'ils appliquent
vraiment les effets recommandations
parce que je pense qu'il ya vraiment des
vies en jeu et c'est pour une question
importante aujourd'hui en même temps
ceux qui sont déjà quoi zone et chez eux
et qu'ils commencent à être anxieux ou
avoir peur parce que c'est important de
les rassurer de les accompagner de désir
et de penser à autre chose en fait
finalement
et si vous appliquez déjà les mesures
nécessaires le dire c'est plus
nécessaire d'être ultra anxieux à papa
ça
mais difficiles à communiquer oui c'est
ça c'est un peu comme si été trouvé
entre les deux c'est à dire être prudent
et faire attention mais d'un côté pas
non plus paniquer enfin quand on voit
les gens qui dévalise les rayons c'est
complètement faux parce qu' on est loin
du d'un risque de pénurie alimentaire
actuellement en europe et on sait qu'on
a pas mal de stocks actuellement et que
et qu'en plus ça va pas non plus dur est
super longtemps qu'un panneau un non
plus c'est quand on voit les gens qui se
battaient pour du papier toilette
conduire sur le papier toilette c'est
devenu un symbole de choix afin que
c'est pas le plus important
ouais voilà ce que d'autres points quand
pas encore abordé qui tomberait
importants apportés à aborder je pense
peut-être rappeler qu'en fait pour
évaluer la lie risques liés à une
épidémie il faut vraiment s'intéresser à
plusieurs paramètres et indicateurs et
pas qu'un seul bon en termes un peu plus
épidémiologique donc le taux de létalité
tas dans quelle proportion le virus se
transmet également la période
d'incubation d'un sexualité tous ces
paramètres là c'est des paramètres qui
vont évoluer au cours du temps là sont
également spécifiques d'une région voire
d'un pays parce qu'il ya ça dépend des
systèmes de santé la population
également et donc faut faire attention
je pense à tous les chiffres qu'on peut
lire dans la presse et tout faut faire
attention du coup si c'est des chiffres
au niveau mondial au niveau national si
on a par exemple donné le taux de
létalité selon les classes d'âge parce
que ça c'est intéressant c'est que le
risque n'est pas le même chez les jeunes
et chez les personnes âgées ou chez les
gens atteints de comorbidité donc c'est
à dire d'hypertension de cancer ou qui
ont des maladies cardiovasculaires en
même temps et donc je pense à
intéressant d'avoir en tête que ça ça va
évoluer et également comme on est en
cours d'épidémies ce normal qu'ils aient
un haut niveau d'incertitude est plus un
peu à la fin de l'épidémie qu'on en
saura plus et forcément on a également
de la malle dessous détection de deux
cas alors à ti cul les cas avec des
symptômes légers et asymptomatiques
mais ça on peut pas on peut pas
forcément faire autrement et c'est
également dans la limite de détection
des cas avec les tests d'une part je ne
sais pas comment ils font en corée du
sud mais arriva à faire cent mille tests
de quelques dents chez nous c'est quand
même un peu moins et plus on fait de
détection de cas forcément plus on a de
chances de détecter des personnes
infectées
donc c'est également pour ça que les
indicateurs varient selon les pays
on s'intéresse au taux de létalité
qu'est le ratio enfin le rapport simple
entre le nombre de décès sur le nombre
de cas confirmés sont des tacles
beaucoup de cas confirmés forcément le
taux de létalité il va diminuer ouais je
voudrais d'ailleurs entendu dire qu'en
corée du sud
en gros pour faire un test on peut être
conduire un endroit voir le test et puis
on repartait qu'on avait la réponse le
lendemain par email crise comme ça moi
c'était vraiment efficace et très peu
pas besoin d'eux
je pense qu'en fait en asie ils ont
beaucoup appris de l'épidémie du stress
en 2002 2003 puisque c'était assez
similaire et du coup je pense qu'ils
m'ont un peu tirer les conséquences
d'une telle épidémie et qu'il faut
réagir en fait assez rapidement parce
que plus on réagit rapidement mieux ce
sera pour contenir cette épidémie et
c'est clairement ce que tu vois pas ce
que est ce que tu penses que fin c'est
peut-être un peu trop tôt de parler de
tout ça mais à priori il pourrait avoir
d'autres épidémies dans le futur en tout
cas ce que on pourrait mieux se préparer
qu'est ce qu'il faudra faire pour être
mieux préparé ce que je pense que non
votants lui poser une question plus
simplement parce que tu penses que nous
autres vigueur vulgarisateur on aura dû
être plus réactif
qu'est ce qu'on a mal fait nous c'est
difficile à dire
je pense que c'est ce qui est
intéressant c'est de jeu trouvait
c'était de vulgariser ce qui sortait en
terme de deux rapports scientifiques au
niveau de l'om est sur une publication
scientifique mais avec des termes plus
simples pour le grand public et que ça
je pense est assez intéressant et comme
tu disais faire prendre conscience aux
gens rapidement que c'est pas on va dire
c'est pas de la rigolade et qu'il faut
être du coup assez prudent et faire
attention a justement à adapter en
enfin à prendre c'est à mettre en place
ces gestes barrières qui normalement au
final devrait être fait de façon
naturelle puisque c'est des simples
règles d'hygiène quand on répète de se
laver les mains de tousser dans son
coude
ça n'a rien de révolutionnaire on va
dire
mais je pense que je pense que vu
peut-être communiqué un peu plus tôt et
je trouvais ce qui serait intéressant
c'est également de comment on va sans
doute peut-être faire là au niveau du
café des sciences s'est donné une liste
de sites d'informations fiables c'est
une bonne initiative
parce que là je suis en train de voir la
séquence a changé mais dont tout nous
donne a commencé à notre la vidéo on l'a
on va commencer a décidé de la faire
jeudi dernier comme je vais bientôt une
semaine j'ai pas mal à réfléchir à
est-ce qu'on aurait pu faire ça plus tôt
c'était en fait assez compliqué je pense
de faire ça plus tôt il y aura fallu
quelqu'un de finances l'initiative de
comme toi je savais que quelqu'un
initiative et c'était très bien j'ai
trouvé que c'était très bien
ouais faut aussi convaincre les autres
c'est juste lancé initiative qui était
assis derrière et on voit mal à piger
essayez donc c'est ça côté anglophone
c'est poussé pas mal de gens côté
anglophone à faire la même chose et et
elle va un peu plus par là on peut le
dire aujourd'hui c'est que du coup en
france on a eu plusieurs joueurs d'avant
sur le côté anglophone
bon il n'était plus avancés en france
que si que dans une anglophone mais mais
voilà c'est je pense qu'il y ait eu un
retard côté anglophone qui était un
petit peu dommage va dire si c'est
vraiment pas évident parce que vont
enfin commencer à parler si j'en ai
parlé dans les crimes avec avec thibaut
giro avec me suffit le hamas a fait son
annonce vraiment alarmiste mercredi la
semaine dernière avant ça il avait fait
aussi d'autres rapports très inquiétant
mais mercredi dernier vraiment été
alarmiste
et face s'est passé quelque chose qui
qui qui a permis de nous bouger on va
dire que c'est un truc qui m'a permis de
me dire auquel là on peut bouger le café
des sciences parce que le hamas a
communiqué que moi ce qui m'a fait
également par exemple un peu ce prix et
c'est quand le danemark ils ont décidé
du coup de tout fermer pendant deux
semaines
donc c'était la semaine passée je crois
et on va dire moi j'avais jamais vu une
démesure comme ça aussi drastiques et
enfin en europe le dire et du coup ça
c'était à ses fins a montré quand même
là l'importance de la gravité de la
situation pour prendre de telles mesures
qui ont des conséquences importantes au
niveau social et économique ça que ça ça
va être ma record jusqu'au bout je sens
qu'il y aura beaucoup de critiques à
venir aussi sur la vitesse de gestion de
la crise grand par le gouvernement
français n'est pas moi et cette histoire
de municipales qui ont pas été adulé oui
est ce que pensent que le gouvernement
est ce que le gouvernement français a
vraiment pu faire aller plus vite
je pense qu'on aurait pu lancer ce type
de mesures là une semaine plus tôt c'est
de le faire un peu avant parce que on a
quand même vu ce qui se passe c'est en
janvier et février en asie en chine au
japon en corée du sud le nombre de cas
qui a explosé et eux ils ont pris
également des mesures assez rapidement
donc des fois la fermeture des écoles
la mise en quarantaine des distanciation
social l'envoi de l'information par les
téléphones ou le tressage un peu des
gens par l'état des téléphones et donc
en fait peut-être comme on réduit un peu
plus s'inspirer de ce qui a été fait en
asie en janvier-février et mettre ça en
place un peu plus rapidement par exemple
quand on voit qu'en qu'on manque de
masques
peut être qu'on aurait cru qu'on voit ça
un peu plus parce que c'est ça c'est
vraiment
étant de ne pas avoir de protection en
particulier pour les professionnels de
santé qui sont en ligne directe avec les
malades
ca c c'est vraiment un aspect embêtant
ouais ouais c'est après ça que je pense
que c est facile de rejeter la faute aux
autres
j'ai envie d'y aller et venir nous le
café des sciences aaas et pas bougé bon
c'est bouger quand on s'est bougé sert
une semaine c'est ma bouche et il ya
deux semaines oui mais pourquoi j'avais
fait une vidéo aussi du coup il ya
maintenant dix jours donc une j'avais
filmé ça le 4 mars
il ya deux quasiment deux semaines et la
vidéo est pas non plus complètement à
leur avait pas aussi alarmistes je pense
que ce qu'elle aurait dû être
mais c'est facile de dire ça après coup
comme ça vaut je l'ait fait
je pensais que c'était le bon niveau de
d'alarmisme vois pas ce que je veux dire
c'est pas facile que oui oui ça c'est
sûr que c'est toujours plus facile de
critiquer après et on n'est pas non plus
la place des actuellement des
gestionnaires de risque en fermant par
exemple l'avait vu quand j'avais
travaillé au ministère de la santé et
donc là on se faisait ce qu'on appelle
de la gestion de risque alimentaire donc
c'est prendre des décisions de
d'interdire ou d'autoriser des produits
alimentaires ou ces choses là et c'est
pas du tout suivi donc ça quand quand
cette fois de prendre un choix on va
dire un peu plus politique ou
réglementaires mais du coup qu'il
casserait les questions les frusques on
peut chercher à améliorer
raisonnablement
pour que la prochaine fois ça se passe
mieux notamment en termes de
communication des résultats
scientifiques ou du communication et
aussi du degré d'alarmisme va avoir pas
juger par exemple dans ma vidéo j'ai pas
recommander aux gens de rester chez eux
il ya dix jours parce que j'aurai
recommandé de limiter leurs interactions
spéciale on va revoir la vidéo puis
après je pense que c'est lié au fait que
l'épidémie elle évolué et s'est
rapidement et je pense qu'il ya un mois
également personnellement il ya
peut-être deux trois semaines je me suis
dit que ça allait rester à quelques
centaines de cas où enfin peut être que
ça n'irait pas aussi vite même puis
c'est peut-être aussi une forme de on a
préféré faire un meilleur un peu les
yeux pour rester rassurer elle pense
qu'elle de ça alors qu'en chine on aime
quand on voit qu'on a dépassé les plus
de 80 mille cas et je pense que
l'histoire un peu de distance
géographique en disant que ça va rester
loin de nous et ouais aussi que c'est
arrivé ça fasse et c'est clairement un
facteur aggravant
ouais non je pense aussi
moi je pense avoir sous-estimé mois la
croissance exponentielle des failles et
des calculs que j'ai fait a pas pas
forcément que g8 que j'ai partagés
publiquement médical que j'ai fait dans
mon corps qui je pense était un trompeur
j'ai préféré bon calcul et samaa ça m'a
amené à être plus rassuré que j'aurais
dû l'être
évidemment je pense à j'avais fait un
calcul pour le est-ce que je devais
aller à ce que j'avais une conférence a
donné à paris un grand du point
et dix joueurs ont peu près et du coup
j'avais décidé d'y aller et le calcul
que j'ai fait c'était ok la priorité que
je chope le co en avion russe lors de ce
truc
j'avais un peu réfléchi aussi apprêtée
que j'ai le corps d'un virus et du
coucou infecte quelqu'un mais ce que
j'avais pas calculer c'est qu'est
l'espérance du nombre de
personne que je pourrai contaminé en
allant à paris et en fait si on y
réfléchit un petit peu j'avais le
courant à virus et que j'ai bien fait
qu'une personne et que cette personne
n'est pas une personne prudente et du
coup a fait prend pas les mesures de
précaution beaucoup de personnes et puis
après ces personnes faisaient en fait
deux ou trois personnes en moyenne on va
dire rapidement j'ai en fait que des
dizaines de milliers de personnes que et
même si la probabilité que ça ça arrive
et est faible pour moi j'avais quand
même estimée à 0,1 pour cent en moyenne
0,1 pour cent fois dix mille personnes
ça fait là après coup je me dis je
n'aurais pas dû y aller c'était vraiment
dangereux en tout cas beaucoup plus
dangereux que ce que je croyais que
j'aille à paris enfin je pense que c'est
des conférences intéressantes que les
données ça peut faire avancer d'autres
choses dans d'autres domaines aussi mais
dont il en est il des algorithmes et je
crois que j'avais pas mesuré du tout
l'ampleur du dilemme auquel j'étais
confronté et je pense que c'est le cas
de beaucoup beaucoup de gens je pense
pas avoir été le seul à avoir fait ce
genre d'erreur je pense qu'après c'est
parce qu'on n'a pas forcément eu de
telles épidémies
et de telle ampleur dans ces dernières
années puisque six durant comprend les
dernières épidémies fortement médiatisée
ebola ça reste très concentré en afrique
de l'ouest comme ça qu'est bollène en
plus et ben non inclus il va
transmissible de façon interne et
humaine faut vraiment être en contact
très rapprochés avec les malades voire
touché le sang ou des choses comme ça
pareil pour les maladies plus comme le
chikungunya ou zytek son vectorielle se
tait et on ne les avait pas en europe
pour le h5n1 en 2009
là pour cette grippe bien une grande
partie des cas qui était ce un symptôme
est mêlé avec la un peu la grippe
saisonnière et c'était pas une c'est un
peu différent enfin je trouve au monde
après je pense aussi que les limbes où
les estimations que j'avais vu passer
jusque là il était beaucoup moins
alarmiste que ce qui s'est passé
vraiment j'avais pas enfin je ne vais
pas là c'est des trucs genre ça doubler
tous les six jours que j'ai c'est comme
ça qu'est ce qui est déjà assez horrible
cette double tout ici en fait l'heure
n'est plus à doubler tous les tous les
trois jours voire trois jours et du coup
ben moi j'ai été pris de court aussi
rapport à une estimation
on est vraiment dans un quartier qui est
pire que qu'est-ce que je pouvais penser
je pensais avec les données que j'avais
à l'époque
donc cessez un peu excusable va dire
mais c'est aussi aussi la limite
finalement 2-2 ce qu'on se rende des
données qu'on a deux noms conséquence
des écoutes essaie d'anticiper aussi les
cas qui pourrait être pire je pense que
c'était important et c'est peut-être pas
un truc que j'ai pas assez faire une
autocritique
c'est pas évident non plus de suivre
je pense que pour un peu mieux saisir
l'ampleur de cette épidémie faux seront
justement lire les publications qui
viennent de sortir dans les journaux
scientifiques et quand on travaille à
côté on n'a pas forcément non plus le
temps de faire ça tout le temps mais ça
ça prend du temps
par exemple moi j'avais vulgariser sur
mon blog
quelques-uns c'est que c'est m'a pris
pas mal de temps à lire ses publications
et à à vulgariser tout ça donc ouais
voilà ce que tu penses que le veut ce
que tu étais content d'être du travail d
épidémiologie tous cas il aura plus cher
plus sûr pour moi
moi je peux te contente parce que
franchement dès le allées autour de chez
plus c'était le 20 janvier mais télé les
premières publications dans les plus
grands journaux médicaux comme des
landes c'est tout le n o j aime les
français à aller assez vite où ils ont
très rapidement donné les
caractéristiques cliniques des patients
infectés en chine
on a rapidement su quelles étaient les
symptômes dans quelles proportions
également on a eu des premières
estimations du taux de reproduction de
base donc un peu le niveau de
transmission du virus
on a bu moi j'ai ramené à une bien huit
ou dix est toutes les sorties en pré
print ou en journal review assez
rapidement donc non je trouve plutôt les
épidémiologistes ont été assez réactif à
tout et surtout l'essai anglais
anglophone je trouve dans la côte sur
moi je trouve sur twitter qui avait pas
mal d'épidémiologistes à l'international
qui faisait pas mal de vulgarisation
fait en tout cas d'explication et
d'information
par exemple sur twitter un peu moins je
sais pas ce qu'il en est de la suisse
mais en france
- communiquer dessus
bah moi j'ai beaucoup suivi un mec
s'appelle marcel salat et parce qu'il
est dans le milieu artistique
il a déclaré c'est un train flanc mais
après tu étais beaucoup en anglais par
exemple en suisse il y avait justement
j'avais vu une étude le 25 janvier de
christian alto ce je sais pas dans
quelle université suisse il aimait il
avait fait justement une estimation de
du taux de reproduction de base à partir
des données chinoises
la transmission du virus et donc non ce
truc là justement les épidémiologistes
ont plutôt rapidement réagi du coup
cessé
on va dire que les épidémies sont bien
huilés les vulgarisateurs peut-être mis
un peu de temps
très sûr ça même si pour 20,6 et c'est
clairement difficile après ça ne sont
pas professionnels un point sur ça donc
c'est vraiment compliqué est ce que tu
sais par hasard ce qui a eu des passes
que vont pas dans son discours maps on
dirait qu'il a été informé par les
scientifiques est ce que tu as un scoop
c'est keira si les délires à ses proches
ils peuvent s'activer rapidement comme
ça entre entre la recherche et la
politique buy and justement des beaucoup
d'interaction entre le gouvernement et
par exemple la santé publique france
donc santé publique on s'est regroupés
avant l'institut national de prévention
et de veille sanitaire donc la nbs et
c'est eux qui faisait la veille pour les
maladies infectieuses et d'études de de
ce type de crise donc qui suivent par
exemple l'épidémie de grippe donc deux
ans tu as des gens qui ont une réelle
expertise
scientifique sur les maladies
infectieuses
après je pose qui a également des
discussions au niveau des universités du
gouvernement puisque moi je suis quand
j'étais au ministère en belgique ont
échangé beaucoup avec les universités
par exemple une fois on s'est intéressé
aux nanoparticules dans l'alimentation
et du coup on avait recherché qui
étaient des experts universitaires dans
ce domaine là pour en discuter justement
donc âpre au final c'est toujours le
gouvernement qui a le dernier mot en
termes de décisions politiques et les
scientifiques ont juste un rôle des avis
scientifiques c'est-à-dire d'évaluation
du risque
ouais et quand du groupe tata tv tu as
peut-être eu des expériences cancon
communiqué le risque comme ça des gens
qui sont que j'étais pétition ça se
passe bien enfin qu'en troquant le loyer
communiqué je pense qu'il faut mieux
quand c'est une crise plus grave comme
ça je pense qu'il faut mieux également
collaboré avec vraiment des
professionnels de la communication parce
qu'en tant que peut-être scientifique ou
expert en réglementation
on n'aura peut-être pas la même façon de
communiquer
sur le risque que des gens qui seront
vraiment expert en communication mais je
pense que c'est important de collaborer
avec des gens qui seront trouver les
bons mots entre ne pas faire trop peur
mais également appelé la prudence pour
le grand public que je pense ça oui
c'est intéressant mais actuellement fons
d'abord une collaboration entre des gens
qui sont très forts en régularisation
communication en termes de des
virologues épidémiologistes la médecine
clinique
c'est ce que j'imagine en janvier ou en
février
le genre de discussion qu'il aurait
fallu avoir un peu facile de dire a
posteriori mais ça serait un truc du
genre
bon c'est probablement pas un truc qui
va être qui va être complètement
horrible fasse pas sûr en tout cas mes
parents il faut vraiment bien se
préparer pour faut acheter des masques
faut acheter d investir dans le
dépistage
si avant d'en augmenter peut-être les
cas préparer les hôpitaux un peu plus à
tout ça je pense que ça laisse un peu la
discussion qui aurait été idéal
je ne sais pas si c'est une discussion
qui a eu lieu que ce lieu puisqu'il y
avait la préparation en france si elle
est ce qu'on appelle le plan blanc et
bleu qui prépare les hôpitaux les
maisons de retraite de santé les et pète
les ehpad les maisons médicalisées à ce
type de situation là à venir donc tu ce
type de discussions après par exemple
pour le le matériel d'équipement en
termes de masse que ça c est ce qu il
aurait fallu un peu plus prévoir en
avant c'est peut-être plus délivrer ces
masques que sur ordonnance
depuis plutôt parce que ça ça a été mis
en place assez récemment qu'on que
conduisent plus acheter des masques
comme ça parce que je pense que enfin
oui forcément il y en avait pas pour
tout le monde et c'est bien que ce soit
prioritaire pour les professionnels de
santé des infirmiers les médecins qui
sont directement en contact ça après
c'est toujours compliqué à une gestion
de crise comme ça et pas sur la
préparation à la crise on va dire à
christ probables surtout à l époque où
c'était s'était pas encore sûr c'est pas
vrai j'avais entendu j'ai eu quelques
retours de joueurs qui qui qui
connaissent un des gens dont l'un d'eux
hospitalier et qui m'ont dit que dans le
monde hospitalier en tout cas en suisse
il y avait un manque de préparation est
très très important et au manque de
confiance on a dix rangs des modèles de
prévision qui suggère est il possible
croissance exponentielle avec
potentiellement des coups rudes pas eu
un manque de préparation par manque de
confiance
finement d'une certaine expertise
scientifique mais c'est vrai que c'est
toujours un peu compliqué quand on voit
par exemple à l'époque de la grippe
aviaire en france on avait commandé des
millions de vaccins qui au final à la
série les parent ici ça si ça avait
servi au final on aurait été content de
les avoir et aller je suis assez bien de
cet épisode où je me souviens d'avoir
pensé aux les gens sur réagissent comme
ça et ça c'est en fait en un sens a vu
l'incertitude qui avait à cette époque
là probablement il n'avait pas tort
je sais pas je n'ai pas téléphoné mais
probablement vous n'avez pas en fait pas
surréagi vu l'incertitude qu'ils avaient
avant quand au moment où ils ont pris la
décision de commander ces vaccins et
aujourd'hui on vit à la situation
opposée où c'est ça un peu ironique
ouais du couffo faut accepter que
pendant un certain temps dans
l'incertitude
on va prendre des décisions qui a
posteriori pourront être vues comme
mauvaise ci a posteriori je pas le fait
que la décision était prise dans
l'incertitude ou bayésiens mais je pense
que c'est devenu vraiment important
maintenant c'est un peu de couleur si
vous passez aux proches ont déjà mais
enfin de quoi que je pense qu'encore
beaucoup d'incertitudes sur le futur
mais si je pense que c'est vraiment
important de développer un peu plus ce
raisonnement avec l'incertitude être un
peu plus à l'aise avec le fait qu'on ne
sait pas mais qu'il faut quand même
prendre des décisions faut quand même
savoir s'il faut se préparer ou pas ce
qu'il faut investir dans l'achat de
masques ou de deux vaccins
aujourd'hui plus dans la recherche sur
les vaccins ou autre chose comme ça à
quel point faut investir dessus je pense
que c'est important de raisonner un peu
plus avec l'incertitude
ouais tu que ça veux que tu es là comme
ça pas forcément un
comment est ce que tu vois un peu le
quels sont les scénarios futurs
possibles de cléty ton visage mais là je
pense que maintenant on va entre
guillemets un peu attendre chez soi et
que le pic de l'épidémie est passé
ouais je pense pas bien un peu plus ou
moins que ça à faire un nom peut pas
vraiment faible fait plus je pense
ouais bon je pense que en tant que
vulgarisateur enfin sur la gamme je
pense qu'il y encore eu une urgence à
peillon dit si vous voulez servir oui
encore moins pendant veut dire des jours
à venir
peut-être une semaine d'audience que dix
jours pour que tout le monde comprenne
la gravité la situation et l'importance
de rester chez ceux là c'est un peu
comme c'est que le loup en tout cas
après le pic
enfin priori enfin si si les gens
respectent un peu les consignes occupée
par rennes là ça va continuer à
augmenter mais a priori ça devrait on
l'espère en tout cas
oui ça va diminuer après dans quelques
semaines peut-être quelques mois
peut-être wristwatch est on prêt après
après il ya aussi donc il eu pas mal de
discussions sur les risque de
réinfection où des dj risque de dirt
contamination d'europe et non avenue
parce que tu en penses que ça sur scène
oui j'avais lu quelques commentaires sur
sur serbe dans les journaux médicaux et
en fait à
apparemment la réinfection c'est quand
même vraiment très peu probable et ça
pourrait être dû à des erreurs de test
puisque en fait les individus qui ont
guéri il garderait un peu d'eux devait
de virer mignan un de particules virales
heures en eu également lieu pour le
moment les tests qu'on utilise pour
confirmer les cas c'est moche et ce dès
ce qu'on appelle des rt pcr
donc c'est en fait en gros
identifier la rn virale du du virus est
un peu plus tard on pourra se base
également sur ce qu'on appelle des tests
sérologiques donc là c'est plutôt se
baser sur les anticorps et qui sont
créées après avoir été infectés et du
coup on va détecter ces anticorps là est
donc là ça pouvait être fait des erreurs
justement de de détection de deux cas
donc de sensibilité tout ça ça serait
donc une bonne nouvelle aussi si c'est
oui parce qu'il ya pas de leur affection
pense qu'il est probable enfin peu
probable je veux dire que qui est
derrière infections en tout cas dans
l'immédiat une bâton d'infecter bonne
nouvelle c'est un peu la tactique que je
pense du royaume uni actuelle je pense
que c'est ce que racontait le premier
ministre c'était d'attendre une yvan une
éventuelle immunité acquise de groupe
acquise de façon passive
mais cette tactique elle est quand même
assez dangereuse puisque il faut quand
même à un nombre vraiment important de
personnes infectées avant d'avoir assez
de gens immunisé pour faire une barrière
à la propagation de l'épidémie
et si on a des millions de personnes
infectées
même avec un ou deux pourcent de
mortalité on aura quand même beaucoup de
décès enfin des conséquences assez
graves
ah oui j'ai vu passer plusieurs trucs
ils disaient qu'ils sont en train de
rétropédaler sûr c'est vrai mais je peux
comprendre ils vont faire comme les
autres pays européens
et récemment des discussions sur le fait
que ce soit potentiellement une guitare
un peu quand comme une grippe
saisonnière que quelque chose qui dise
pure est un peu l'été et revenir ensuite
je pense que c'est compliqué pour le
monde prédire c'est le virus va avoir un
effet saisonnier ou pas puisque en fait
tout simplement on n'a pas vécu une
année avec le virus donc on sait pas
encore comment il va réagir à la chaleur
de l'été si ça va s'atténuer ou pas
encore a priori si on a un effet
saisonnier dans tout l'hémisphère nord
du coup on aurait sans doute une
diminution de l'incidence mais elle est
vraiment tôt pour le dire et si on
compare avec d'autres chorales un virus
si tu prends le coronavirus du
moyen-orient et bien nuit n'avait pas du
tout d'effets saisonniers puisque
justement il vient d'un pays très
chauffe en arabie saoudite
il a continué à se propager en été
malgré la chaleur et l inverse si tu
prends le les coronavirus liés aux
rhumes
mais là-bas comptes t1 effet beaucoup
plus ces zones et donc on sait que c'est
également des fois lié aux gouttelettes
et ses créations qui vole pas de la même
façon en fonction des consciences des
conditions de température et d'humidité
mais c'est pas toujours le cas et je
pense que pour le nouveau coronavirus
est difficile à prédire comment ça va se
passer
non
la grosse inconnue il passe d'un compte
de cette poule je pensais à tous
beaucoup d'incertitudes sur sur ce qu'il
faut faire
voilà donc les lieux cher l'indre trucs
comme avait fait gaffe dans la vidéo je
suis plus qu'il y avait proposé de faire
gaffe on s'aime c'est vraiment une bonne
idée c'est de ne pas corriger les gens à
suivre régulièrement les nouvelles
recommandations en vigueur parce que oui
mais aussi à pinon dans sa réaction à si
vous êtes malade parce que vous avez des
symptômes aujourd'hui qu'est ce qu'il
faut faire
il ya un moment en fait la refondation
c'était d'appeler le 15 en fait les 15e
et surchargé vérifier un moment il ya
une histoire d'appeler votre médecin
traitant mais bon moi je pense que ça
évolue enfin je sais pas trop quelle
était ma temps mais même si je dis un
truc aujourd'hui sera compliqué oui je
pense que c'est mieux d'aller justement
sur le site de votre ministère de la
santé ou des institutions de santé qui
ont les recommandations plus à jour et
et comme tu dis ça a évolué puisque au
début de l'épidémie on disait justement
appelé les urgences mais maintenant
comme il ya beaucoup de gens qui ont eu
peur et de personnes potentiellement
infectées fin ça et vite été débordés et
maintenant oui les recommandations ont
évolué et pour ceux que ça tu as aussi
alors on est en train de lui aussi des
gens va peut-être sortir un peu mes
empreintes sens encore privé avec tout
ça mais on en train de réfléchir à des
recommandations sur ce qu'il faut
recommander notamment la manière de
communiquer notamment donc avec des
psychologues notamment ça c'est bien de
tourner choses par quelque chose de
positif plutôt que quelque chose de
négatif des frasques ans voir si vous
voulez pas mourir c'est pas génial on va
dire
ouais c'est que ce pour sauver la vie
vous pouvez c'est beaucoup plus efficace
est entièrement d'accord je me souviens
que quand j'étais au ministère on a vu
en moi une formation avec l'autorité
européenne de sécurité alimentaire qui
justement avait discuté sur la
sémantique employés comment discuter
autour des chiffres tout ça avait son
importance
ouais ça se fait entièrement d'accord
baqouba du coup merci pour cette
discussion parce que vous écoutez ça
respire que vous êtes chez vous faire
train d'écouter ça et que prenez soin de
vous prenez soin de votre entourage
il a bientôt du coup probablement mais
c'est également avoir proposé de
discuter
merci à toi